Speaker 1: OK, this you really have to see
on Fox and Friends yesterday morning there,
one of their three hosts, Brian Kilmeade,
was reduced to arguing with children about
Trump vs. Biden in a segment that if he was
able to feel shame, he should be completely
humiliated by his participation in this segment.
An 11 year old kid pretty accurately makes
the case that he's feeling better about getting
back to school and about handling the pandemic.
Now that Joe Biden is president and is dealing
with the coronavirus in a serious way, completely
reasonable position.
It's an 11 year old kid.
Kilmeade sort of seems to crack.
He didn't like the kids comment, I guess,
and he sort of like responds rudely to the
kid.
It's very weird.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 4: How close are you to getting back
in the room?
What do you miss most about not being in school?
Speaker 5: I miss most obviously seeing my
friends and all the after school activities
that I've done.
And I think that we're very, very close to
getting back to school.
And I think that on the way that our new president
is handling things is a very good way.
And we would not have gone to this if it were
still the last president.
Speaker 4: Really, that's hard to believe
because the last president was saying, I want
every kid back in school.
So luckily for you, what is your hope knowing
the numbers are going down and the governor
might be opening up?
Speaker 1: Did you notice that Kilmeade even
moved on to the next kid right away before
the eleven year old could refute kill Medes?
Completely flaccid counterpoint.
He doesn't want the kid to say another word.
Now, a source at Fox News told me after the
interview, Kilmeade referred to the kid as
a poopy head.
And that seems on brand with the way this
entire segment went.
Who thought this was a good idea?
Who who conceives of this segment and thinks
it's a good idea.
And if it wasn't Kilmeade and the segment
was put in front of him, why not react by
saying, interesting, it's so great that you're
involved in following what's going on?
What can can Brian Kilmeade feel anything
but complete and total shame over this segment?
Or at least should he?
Who wants to bet that this kid's parents end
up getting threats as a result of the segment?
That's the serious thing.
And unfortunately, it wouldn't be even remotely
surprising to me.
And again, why even try to counter what an
eleven year old is saying?
If you strongly refute a kid, you're beating
an eleven year old in a debate.
And of course, if the kid makes more sense
than you, which was actually the case here,
you really look like a moron.
And it's almost like that game show.
Are you smarter than a fifth grader or a sixth
grader or whatever?
It's the Fox News edition of that game show.
And the hosts are losing badly.
Like imagine feeling the urge to debate and
disprove rather than encourage a kid for their
involvement in what's going on in the world
around them.
And this is how propaganda motivates people
to behave.
Every differing opinion.
It doesn't matter how minor.
It doesn't matter how nonthreatening the purveyor
of the opinion is.
It is perceived as a threat that must be dealt
with immediately.
You know, interesting.
Thanks for sharing your opinion.
It's great to see kids involved in their country
taking an interest.
Great.
No, no.
Instead, Kilmeade argues and then argues with
and then cuts off an eleven year old kid.
Now, I'm being totally serious here.
This is not I'm not joking about this.
If you replaced Kilmeade with this eleven
year old on Fox and Friends, it would be a
way better and more interesting show.
I might become a regular viewer of Fox and
Friends if this kid was mixing it up with
Steve Doocy and Ainsley Erhart instead of
Brian Kilmeade, that would make it a better
show.
And I'm not kidding when I say the kid seems
better informed than most of the Fox News
audience.
I have no doubt whatsoever about that.
Now, for a moment, let's deal with the substance
of Brian Kilmeade rebuttal.
Kilmeade is right.
Trump said, open every school and put every
kid back in school.
It was the middle of a pandemic.
We had not nearly enough testing, no guidelines
about how to safely open schools absent vaccination.
And we had no vaccines.
We had no precautions.
We had no preventative measures.
Trump just said, open it all up.
It's true, Trump said it, but it would have
been insanely dangerous to open schools when
and how Donald Trump said he wanted to do
it.
And fortunately, it didn't happen.
Now Joe Biden is doing it and it's being done
safely.
And it's abundantly, abundantly clear who
got the right side of that argument.
It wasn't Kilmeade.
It was the eleven year old kid.